do you wear do you keep pockets on the
side of your pants because you don't
want to carry there's fishing stuff in
there oh
come on now he's got his hooks in this
chin looking cute today look at that new
shirt yeah the flannel is that new shirt
nice flannel this is a new shirt from
bass pro shops
i'm wearing i'm wearing a cozy i have a
hernia this is a christmas color
and i have very few you do give it a
fall don't like the way yeah i don't
like the way it sits on my body but i
got it anyways yeah a little bit it's a
little bit open here makes it brooks or
whatever yeah it's a it's dragonbone it
gives a very warm feeling to it but it
is colored yeah
well i was in new york and it's [ __ ]
cold is it ooh is there snow was it no
but that wind whistles through the old
it no it wasn't wet cold like you forget
about you forget about bill talk about
new york you forget about the winter
okay yeah and you also forget about the
summer i don't know i like the summer
what's the summer like when you gotta
live in new york july and august dog
days the dog days and when he bounces
off the reflection of the don't forget
all the smog oh really from the cars
either the subway yeah it's great that's
like a teenager ninja turtle it doesn't
smell like yeah at all
and the streets in there yeah
it's uh yeah it gets to you so
again there are a lot of really nice
places in this country and then you look
at the sky and it's gray as [ __ ] or it's
raining or it's simply too cold for your
face
we didn't see the sun one time in
seattle enjoy that overrated enjoy that
i don't know anybody that wants to like
live and see it like that logan wanted
to move to seattle back in the day he's
crazy and then he goes oh wait this is a
little too rainy and it rains
you you can keep it yes does it come
with a subscription of betterhelp.com
yeah i was depressed i don't have
depression i was there we were about to
get coffee we're all calling no i said a
word
that's the story i told you when i and i
had done a gig i had a great gig and
then i i was invited to a house by this
these kind of like profes yuppie
professionals they were really cool in
seattle yep and i go i'll come i'm i'm
alone i got nothing i [ __ ] come and
hang out at this party you know with
this people that came to my show they
seem really cool
that i've never seen
that much cocaine done by adults in my
life
well that's what you do in seattle
because you're so depressed
i'm trying to be like kurt cobain they
do that too
they do that too we went to kurt
cobain's house yeah late at night we
were chilling later
i know chappelle had been down i went
hey you want to go to kurt cobain's
house he was like
right now there's no traffic it's 12
minutes from our yeah did you take an
uber or you took no we drove we had a
rental yeah yeah we drove down there now
that house now they now they tore down
the original i'll see you the house now
worth about 12 million buckaroos and it
is nice
nice that is ridiculous i mean kurt
cobain he was rich as well the area is
super nice well that's where i was
there's a there's a little bench now but
that's a tribute to kurt cobain we can't
really see much
i was on i always say i was there and
the house was on a lake yes
it's that late yeah it's so nice [ __ ] i
look to the property like one house like
22 million the other one's 14 million
still everybody's depressed that's why
they were all doing cocaine in their 40s
i was waiting for someone's heart to
stop and i'm talking about just like
bricks
i couldn't believe it i was like
yeah seattle's weird like
so we stayed like on capitol hill down
there where that uh chazz district was
at um
it's different down there it's different
than white white like i'm white they're
but they're they're different that
they're white weirdos that's the weirdo
whites
white people get when they're when
they're too white and they they they
spend enough time together like that
they get super weird this game gets all
clear they get very educated have a lot
of money and they're super white they
grow they'll do weird [ __ ] like they
grind their own coffee by hand yeah they
do all kinds of exercises weird [ __ ]
they do a pour over for no reason and
they're they're they'll roast the beans
only like halfway and they're sour yeah
so you like lemon yeah
they [ __ ] up coffee even now what's
interesting with the new iphone so it is
pitch dark out there yeah but the iphone
makes the background look like we're
there during the day like some psychos
that's amazing you can't go there during
the day oh you're there at night every
day tonight it's eleven o'clock at night
yeah you don't say well that's that's
right next to the house i had a joint in
my hand yeah you did you're smoking
weird that's [ __ ] a little weird you
got high started crying yep yeah i
started crying you did you know what's
so why did you start crying fun fact
when there was a point in time where i
spent like a month there you didn't care
camp you didn't cry i didn't cry
i spent a month in seattle teaching
cheer camps and it was shortly after my
brother had passed so i was like super
depressed
you know i would go to that bench like
every other day and just journal really
yeah that bench yeah so it was kind of
it was kind of wild going back to it
because i hadn't been to it since i was
like super depressed yeah so it's kind
of wild like coming back with like this
new
life you know what i mean yeah because
i'm i'm i'm more excited about it like
yeah yeah i love kurt cobain like all
the stuff with what he represented like
so i don't it's not a sad thing for me
it's haunted but i i i tend to write we
asked david if he wanted to go so you
know j who is it you me and jay me you
jay mark yeah that's right mark went i'm
like who else wants to go dave was like
i ain't going to that white man's
[ __ ] house at least kirk obey's like
i don't give a [ __ ] i like dude kurt
cobain
and do what are you guys going to do i'm
like all right we'll see you later yeah
i don't know what i don't know it was
dope he loves kurt cobain yeah yeah who
doesn't dude
just a b wait how much was the house
worth uh i they bought it i think three
years ago for like nine million but now
it's worth because the person that had
it before them had it for like 23 years
and they bought it for like three i
think at the time they had for 25 years
yeah because it was the house is stupid
nice stupid nice but they tore down that
part where
uh
that's his that's his l.a that's true
he's la [ __ ]
you gotta type in seattle yeah they tore
down that uh
whoever bought it after he had passed
tore down that uh
that greenhouse
is that where he killed himself he
killed himself upstairs i thought yeah
it was like in a greenhouse type thing
also killed himself he was murdered in
that house let's be real that's what
they say i mean that's what everybody
says i mean just just that gun just the
gun
to be able to try to shoot yourself with
the gun we haven't heard from courtney
cox at all
she's long alone i i saw her a couple
times um in person and she's even even
courtney loves dad thinks she did it is
that true yeah he didn't talk to her
yeah
the daughter doesn't talk to her like a
little bit and he killed kirkland yeah
she's a little out there yeah she's uh
she's a really strange cow she she did
some acting work she was in like sons of
anarchy yeah one season i got stories
about her it's interesting but maybe
she's you better bro no um i just know
she's come around pretty well i don't
know
but where we performed was outside
seattle it seems to be tough to sell
tickets right now man oh she's older
look at her though she's probably got
she's 50 something yeah she's got money
you know yeah
is she um
she does she get along with her she's
very [ __ ] up what what she's very
[ __ ] yeah what uh i guess she spent a
lot of that nirvana money
after he had passed
because she because the house posted
where she goes uh nirvana or go home
click on that i'm sure the comments are
not friendly
[Music]
oh she uh made all the comments limited
on our posts
oh she did yeah that's not gonna be
friends how do you know it says at the
very bottom
comments on this post have been limited
yeah yeah yeah but that's tough yeah
that's man yeah those aren't gonna be
nice yeah but let's see i think i think
if you we're going to headline in
seattle
it's so woke and
and the virus out there you know they're
like we had to show
proof of vaccination like you have to
wear ma
again every once in a [ __ ] on la man
dude compared to everything besides
seattle besides texas and florida and
arizona i get that they're they're you
know the wild west but outside that dude
it's yeah i mean la we have it pretty
good
go to seattle go to new york it is
locked i know it's trendy to [ __ ] on
[ __ ]
uh la dude we don't have it that bad now
we have the worst governor but dude it's
not that bad you get outside here
because this was uh
this was like 30 minutes outside of
seattle well and everett you know they
they frown upon seattle so it's like
they came out have you seen the the
protests in places like melbourne
and and oh for the lockdown and nobody's
reporting on it do you it's the
because they want people to think
everybody's cool with it we're not we're
sick of it
people get nuts man that is [ __ ]
crazy yeah it's nuts i mean jesus yeah
and it's just
melbourne right
no dude it's all over it's all over the
world i mean america not so much but no
no i'm talking about just melbourne like
as far as australia no australia new
zealand's bad with their lockdowns they
have curfew and then uh uh [ __ ] uh
it's just too much ireland has protests
why'd you bring up tim kennedy uh he
posted something about it oh there you
go some of the largest protests in
history happening in rome france
melbourne all over the world you don't
aren't seeing for a reason yeah
yeah look at that and they don't report
any of it because they don't want people
to think i mean some of this might be
anti-vaxxed stuff which you know
as opposed to it's not antibiotics
it's locked down okay
right right yeah don't don't spread that
that's anthony no i i thought that's
what it was but no it's i'm sure there's
some of it but really it's them you know
getting like they want to go to work
they want to live their life normally
it's like stop with this the don't act
like this is killing uh more than one
percent not even that anymore
you're you're you're you're spreading
misinformation
i mean i remember there was one point in
time i knew so many people that had
coveted right now i don't know anyone
that has covet
i don't know well with that new variant
my buddy jimmy that new they're trying
to scare everybody with
you know i have a friend who's on the on
the board the cdc and today during the
california meeting they're like
we don't get where all the news is
getting like it's no more dangerous than
the original and it also has really mild
effects
the head of the the health organization
in uh africa south africa the lady came
out she goes yeah we've it's hair off
the strain hair she goes it's more mild
than the original she's like i don't get
like talk about that
yeah yes and the the stock market took a
huge crash uh jimmy burke got it he was
on his way to see his mother who's 88 or
you cannot have covert she would die
yeah and and uh five minutes before that
his girlfriend said i just tested
positive he goes oh [ __ ] they his friend
turns her around there are 12 people
waiting for him he goes and get tested
he's positive oh well he was like i'm a
little chill but he had the vaccination
he goes i'm little chills but i could
play tennis right now like he's just
totally fine totally fine breathes right
through it i mean he got vaccinated so
apparently when you get vaccinated it
helps you if you if you catch covet even
then yeah but his girlfriend had the
booster as well and she got it yeah and
but she's okay she's fine yeah it's not
it's not bad but i i'm surprised
hopefully hopefully when that pill comes
out which is gonna just annihilate
everything when that comes out can't get
it on covets hey listen it's over hey
you're not gonna die from covert i wish
you got to live
with a heart transplant or if you have
you know underlying conditions yeah yeah
some crazy flu though i mean yeah you
get the flu and you have unlike health
conditions
yeah so so so we've done a great job yes
it's over though combating covet yeah
with vaccines with therapeutics
and i i just i i watch i was on the
plane and i watched these this couple
and they're just they're wiping down
everything they're wiping down
everything they they just ate a noise
you're still on a plane with a bunch of
people but a little adversity you just
shows the true colors of it a little
adversity you realize you're surrounded
by a bunch of [ __ ] can you imagine if
we get it
if a virus is really some real shields
15 of us no i'm locking them i mean of
course yeah of course you are but i'm
saying can you imagine i'll be the guy
wiping down the plane and [ __ ] but it
shows you what could happen to a society
that's working it just shows you how
soft society is you got to be ready you
got to be ready
now you got some nice legs on you i got
i got some i get some turkey legs you
got some meaty quads dude if we crash on
a plane you eat me like first i'm going
right for you
and i don't use this word i gotta be
honest with you your legs look delicious
let me ask you a question i'll butter
them up for you what's your
secret peloton daddy what and listen the
new year is starting everybody's waiting
till january 1st don't wait man get a
peloton right now it's a great workout
you'll be excited to get your workout on
with peloton they got 20-minute classes
30-minute classes 40 minutes you get
your apple bottom as well dude that's
right that's where you get your
delicious lower body that's where this
peach comes from man they have great
instructors my favorites robin all right
ally's great as well you listen to hip
hop country rock pop everything in
between classes also includes cycling
strength yoga bar meditation yeah dude
if you're looking for me on there my
name is thickboyprez on there you can
find me on there all right you get free
access to the pelton app when you
purchase peloton bike listen i'm on the
road all the time i can find a peloton
bike damn near anywhere your favorite
classes go where you go this holiday
season visit onepelton.com to learn more
try peloton classes for free for the
rest of the year free for free new
members only visit onepelton.com
app to learn more terms of play peloton
when your workout is a joy it's a joy to
work out and get that delicious lower
body
talk to me about the zebra dude because
behind every fight is a world of data
statistics details same goes for
insurance policy your time on insurance
here man with the zebra you can compare
car and home coach from every major
insurance company they do all that in
under five minutes they do all the work
for yeah giving you all the facts so you
make the right decision it's fast man
it's super fast to find the right price
just for you in fact the zebra saves the
people an average of 922 bucks a year
on home and auto combine that's right
they do the details man they focus on
the details so you don't have to worry
about it save time and money in minutes
compare quotes for free at the zebra.com
slash fighter that's the zebra.com
fighter
yeah i need i need
how about mark came to seattle with us
and he's on plane and mark was eating
and his mask was off and this uh like
bigger lady like you know out of shapely
next to him goes i just want you to know
i'm going to stick on a mask this won't
be up front so you know if between bites
you put your mask on i'm a bit of
stickler when it comes to it it's cool i
guess no she said no she said i'm a
police i'm a yeah i'm a mass
i just want to be up front with that i
told mark well [ __ ] you're working
overtime today
better clock on in [ __ ] working
overtime you know it's like all right
wait what's this pill
uh there's a pill coming yeah there's a
pill coming out soon hopefully fda
approves it where um
you if you feel symptoms of covet it
gets it like cures it like this attacks
it real quick yeah they said it a drop
possible like you won't have to go to
the hospital anymore for coving
this is it right here game changer yeah
you're watching a fight
which ones
uh the uh
did you watch the montreal fight sure
didn't you tell them on triller yeah
it's very rare i watched a trailer fight
yeah
i like the shade that's thrown at the
ufc how did the frank mirror fight go
did he fight this weekend frank
miraflopoulov and i think it should be a
eye-opening experience for a lot of
people when these mma guys want to fight
like you know you're a world champion
boxer who fought anthony joshua how did
they not know that bubba they know it
but they think that because these rules
are different
that they can grapple uh and get under
hooks and control them and it's just not
that easy don't go ahead and play this
wait this is the guy that really don't
boxers don't boxers do a lot of
underhook no because they get separated
by the refs okay they usually don't
allow it um go ahead and play this gym
i'll play two different versions this
one i can use online so i'll play the
actual footage after this one okay this
is such a bad idea
this is at the end of the first round oh
yeah yeah
that doesn't do it justice show though
i'll show you i'll show you this one
give me one second though
um i don't like seeing this i don't like
seeing frank i don't like that at all i
know that's that's pretty bad
all right here we go
[Music]
frank is just too tough for his own good
boom watch this
so they should probably stop it right
there boom definitely stop it there
right yeah look at this nope he's
letting it go look at pool up he's like
what the [ __ ]
finally
jesus christ that was true what the [ __ ]
they're not even using a bad idea
they're using brown's clothes
it's like a mix it's in between [ __ ]
kids terrible idea you're you're you're
boxing with a guy like pulev
now for frank's defense he got paid more
off that fight than he did fighting
brock lesnar okay
okay but okay you're still taking crazy
that didn't look yeah damn it's not good
damn yes could have been even worse it's
not i mean doesn't get much worse than
that bubba
it it looked to me yeah all right what
what it didn't even look like pull up
was
gearing up he just went yeah it was like
a straight right dang and then he's
definitely gearing up yeah yeah that was
a hard [ __ ] right hand
a little hard right hand
but you know how sometimes you see like
those guys like dylan white just goes
boom and from from left field
throws that [ __ ] yeah that's a good
thing it's all you need
yeah he just helped her just that that
that just that he's very out on his feet
i mean i didn't know they were fighting
with
four ounce gloves so what was that it
was like a triangle ring they had four
ounce gloves they would they would allow
like underhooks and like
you you could seat belt
um
that's boxing though i mean it's not
though b it's not that's not boxing so
the gloves are a little bit bigger it's
like in the mixture
yeah i don't know in boxing they're
gonna separate that you're not gonna be
able to get under hooks and go to work
and frank thought he'd have an advantage
by closing the disk and under hooks but
oh and then and then and then dirty
boxing inside or something yeah i'm just
controlling them like heavy on the head
elbows
you can do spinning back fists though
what yeah and matt matron did that did
did it land it landed on the neck and
matt actually he lost the fight but i
think he actually won
a lot of people do [ __ ] crazy
yeah that's a bummer man matt got paid
well too though so you know these guys
are doing for the payday okay just weird
trailers their whole thing is like going
after the ufc saying we put on a better
production the ufc it's like
you had [ __ ] fat joe commentating
dude
i love that joe but dude you talking
about the rapper yeah
we're all set on him and his insights
into fighting
it's very strange
very strange dude that's really weird
hey how about that kevin hart show
though oh my god i'm glad you brought it
up bruh have you seen that new kevin
hart show i don't even know the name of
it uh called true story
we were we were locked in so when we got
to the airbnb james like have you guys
seen the kevin hart stuff and i'm
i was like yeah i love kevin i watch
everything he does and i was like no i
didn't have any desire dude it is the
best work kevin's ever done it is it is
so intense oh so it's it's not funny
it's it's not there's nothing funny
about that's not the funny thing leslie
snipes is his plays his brother brother
dude so it's basically kevin playing
himself but his name's kid in the show
and he's the most famous comic on the
planet so you know and then the people
around him obviously you know vying for
money and stuff like that dude it takes
so many dark turns
i was stressed out though how about
wesley snipes he can he can oh he kills
it he can do it he can let's get it
everybody
did everybody i gotta let these young
kids know like i'm a dramatic actor oh
yeah yeah oh and he comes from new york
bro yeah in the states yeah he said yeah
he said and i'm a master at it yes he is
so i have to show these kids what's up
yes he dude he's so good in it wesley
kevin is so good i'm so glad wesley
snipes is getting his day right now
because he he was in jail
he went through a lot of taxes yeah he's
a good person too dude but i'm telling
kevin it's so [ __ ] good it is it's
the best i've like seen kevin
oh kevin hart like he feel like he gets
better and better it's amazing better
[ __ ] insane so the show so and so the
first one's like an hour and then it's
five 30 30 30 minute parts oh i have to
turn it off because watch it yet no i
have to turn it off i get to episode
four buzzing up to three in the morning
yeah yeah it's so intense who's his
brother plays uh what's he snipes his
brother he's like yeah he's like a
gangster gangster yeah
not like gangster like uh he's like he's
like a hustler he's just [ __ ] a
[ __ ] up brother yeah on the streets
and it's just dude i'm not going to
spoil it for you guys it's
so good damn is this netflix yeah yeah
it's so [ __ ] good kevin crush is it
dude
man when we first started watching on
instagram yeah we were like oh what is
this [ __ ] and then it just
sucked by the end you're like what the
[ __ ] so it's a dramatic it's a drama
there's so many turns so many [ __ ]
turns and it's true story because some
of it is based on no he said the only
thing true is there's a scene at the
beginning it's out so oh yeah where this
white guy they're sitting in first class
recognizes kevin hart and kevin hart
used to have a bit saying the n-word and
the white guy's doing the bit saying the
n-word
like actual words kevin security's like
what the [ __ ] i'm going to beat the [ __ ]
out of the way
he's like no it's cool right kevin's
cool kevin said that actually really
happened in first class yeah this white
guy was like oh man started dropping his
reference to the end he's like honestly
he's like i gotta say er you know saying
that hey yeah he was like you might
ninja you know and kevin's like all
right dude
he said that part's real some people are
still it's so it's the [ __ ]
that part's uncomfortable
oh i was like yeah
well i mean there was this like cringe
compilation of like woke politicians and
people
like aoc trying like when they were
addressing black she's the word crowds
gonna and ain't nothing wrong with that
oh no for real started talking in like
and i was like
what are you doing here
and and you know how sometimes how about
biting like i'm talking about what i
mean you know what i'm saying you're
biting on bro you sing song that [ __ ]
bite it on breakfast i remember that
yeah you ain't black you ain't right no
he's saying no he said it if you if you
don't vote for you ain't black it's so
kind black if you don't vote for me or
something like that [ __ ] conversation
oh that's [ __ ] when when white no the
best the best
change is their case the best your girl
kamala harris with that jesse smallett
[ __ ] well he's on trial today right it's
going out he's [ __ ] so obviously he's
faked all yeah just to get famous still
saying within an hour of that coming out
without her knowing any of the facts she
was defending saying this is a real
problem in our culture no yeah of course
you know this is a racist thing
everybody yeah we're posting pictures of
them i have friends here really dude i
had skeptical hippo eyes from did they
forget what happened did they forget the
story they didn't know oh they just
didn't notice that no but then
months later she came out was like all
right well this isn't what we thought it
was you know like that so he got so he
got um a certain amount of money for
that they negotiated a certain amount of
salary for empire when he was doing the
show
and it wasn't to his specs it wasn't
what he thought he deserved
so what he did was he forged a letter to
himself
with a racist and a homophobic letter
that he wrote to himself that he had
addressed
not that i know
so that it would create uh sort of a
thing
and there you go you will die
oh yeah there you go that's what he did
so now i'm at this my favorite to think
of him drawing this who yeah
and like pasting it together yeah
and then the fact that they wrote mega
no yeah
yeah so he did that obviously not that
smart of a dude but he wrote a check to
the oh tell him about that you know that
right yeah
there were two extras there were two
actors these two nigerian bodybuilders
he obviously wanted to [ __ ] him and he
starts talking to him and the these two
extras um basically he gets them to
stage this attack
writes them a 3 500 check yeah
writes them a 3 500 check but then they
squeal on their bodies oh yeah
they're awesome they're [ __ ] awesome
but they squeal on him so fast they're
like hey for 30 yeah
oh yeah dude he's [ __ ] yeah
you would think well
so so legally he only faces a bunch of
misdemeanors no no i'm saying
career-wise so you can't have that guy
he's an [ __ ] because he's an [ __ ]
look at this they're blind oh they're
buying this
[ __ ] and they got him by the remember
the news they're like they left a noose
behind they dragged me by the neck with
the noose the cops were like it doesn't
look very worn man i don't know it's not
gonna it's not good oh you're trying to
say they dragged him out and this
idiot's still going he's still going if
i would buy my mother's son if i could
ever do that like dude dude remember
when he went in america
yeah for the cops to come
and the cops are like got the letter and
the body it's just it doesn't make sense
well cops
detectives oh they knew they said they
knew right away they know they see this
oh why cause chicago pd it's what they
it's their job
it's like getting in the ring you think
you're a fighter because you can you
beat up on some people who you know and
then you get in the ring with a
professional and they go
i'm not to be you know but but i do
think my back kick is sneaky and then it
bothered me when i threw it back you you
blocked it with your knees not [ __ ] yeah
it's not [ __ ] and i i always thought it
was [ __ ] like i did sort of i really did
because i used it a lot in tournaments
and then you went i've seen that because
i i did it professionally and you
blocked it with your [ __ ] knee and
this is even worse than that much worse
than that because
you talking about the guy who
who's been on the
on the force for 40 years they've seen
everything yeah and they're like well
this doesn't let me see the net he wrote
maggot god damn it did you ever hear the
story yeah yeah it's like the story
about the it's so stupid it doesn't even
yeah it doesn't line up but i feel like
most people online were like kind of
like
all right this seems a little well well
the woke warriors were like yeah let's
get this these culprits yeah yeah yeah
not talking about them talking about
like this but the most normal people
were like
and that letter looks right here i was
reading about these these detectives
this woman disappears she was pregnant
she disappears
and uh she had a friend that you know
she worked with and her friend was
really nice and her friend was also
pregnant and her friend gave birth
to a baby
and so the cops go to ask her a question
the detectives
and they look at her they take a look at
her and they hear a baby they hear the
baby crying upstairs
and the cop immediately went
immediately the detective went
i don't think she had a baby i think
what she did was pretend to have a baby
and she killed this woman cut the baby
out of her shoes
now i would never think that i would
never think that because that's too
insane and too far-fetched he was 100
right that is what she did she
befriended this woman she she told her
husband she was pregnant her husband's a
[ __ ] idiot she's walked around with
like stuff in her figure it out too and
then yeah and then for nine months and
then she killed the woman cut her belly
open and took the baby okay and now now
she had a baby because you can get away
with what was this and the cops went to
the cops
they said can we see the baby
and he said where did you give birth all
right hospital do you mind if we call
yeah she shot herself
yeah right there yeah she wanted that
doesn't end well yeah
you're gonna get caught well you know i
watch all that first 48 and all that
that is [ __ ] insane you and i
wouldn't think that no i would never
think that
but when you watch people when they're
in the interrogation room and the cops
sit down literally the best in the world
interrogating dude like this one girl
she
she was obsessed with her boyfriend he
broke up with her moved on with a new
girl who's a dying piece she was a
dental assistant he moved on to this
girl who's an actual dentist and
gorgeous yeah and she was just harassing
him right harassing him and he has proof
of stuff like that
well
they this girl
gets shot randomly gets shot
and so they just did the dentist his
girl they were supposed to go to mexico
and the day before they leave she gets
murdered in like a mall parking lot
so the cops go okay here we go and um
and who your past said yeah she was kind
of obsessed with me and he goes okay
we'll bring her in brings her in she's
like i didn't know the lady like you
don't know the lady okay and like she's
real talkative and like so he's
interrogating her he's like give me a
break he goes out to talk to the cameras
he's like she 100 is involved and she
hired this kill he goes because i've
been doing this for 30 years most people
when they don't know they don't really
talk like they're shook they're in you
know they're they're even if they didn't
do anything they feel guilty they're
nervous this girl's not nervous
she's talking way too much and he goes
back in and he's like just paint he goes
think out from my side of you he goes
the only connection to this because the
the person who shot him uh was connected
to her she knew him she was so the only
only person in the world who's connected
to a the boyfriend
b the girl who's murdered and three the
shooter is you did you not find that
weird in any facet and eventually so
they couldn't book her then they're like
we're just gonna build the case then
[ __ ] her over she fled to mexico got
away
oh no yeah fled in mexico wow but when
they interrogate them it's like oh they
they know they'll get you you just can't
i mean if you did do it you can't talk
so wait let's take away from all this
for 48 you cannot [ __ ] you you go i want
even if you're not guilty you go i want
my life you don't commit murder on on a
regular basis so so if you're going to
do something like that
they're going to it's not your arena
it's not your reason
and they've seen someone who's committed
murder in the way they act and she was
all like jolly and give him all the info
she's like oh my god this is terrible
like giving all these facts [ __ ] yeah
wait why couldn't they book her right
then and there they didn't have enough
they didn't have another you know what
my friend said i think i told you this
before my friend said and you know this
my liability is that i've always i've
just
i just see the best in people yeah the
problem is that you can collect a lot of
idiots and sometimes you can collect
some bad eggs
and my friend who makes his living by
loaning money to people who are either
worth it or not he just can read human
behavior that's why he has so much money
and he's really good he said to me he
said
i said he's a good guy and he goes he's
not a good guy brian
you just like him
and you like everybody and because you
see the best in people they show you
their best side that's a big lie don't
see anything else then all of a sudden
you move you know you're now you're
great friends with them and you're
bringing them into the group and
all of us go that guy's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's approximating a good guy
yeah and i don't see that that's that's
or you know how like people would say
always um they talk about
government leaders being you know
corrupt or stuff
i don't
i'm always mis
you're optimistic about yeah because i'm
always like you would never do that why
would you do that you want to yeah why
would you yeah i don't you you really
want to do the best like a criminal i
just don't yeah yeah and i think
sometimes that can be a big liability
auditing this article needs to be more
like rogan is way way yeah way better
like he'll read about that [ __ ]
can that [ __ ] just goes he can
i've seen it's a trait yeah his he's
he's i've never seen anybody he can go
like this he can see the guy the guy
says two words i'm not joking you've
been there yeah and he goes that that
guy's uh that guy i don't wanna go he's
a bad guy he gets away from him yeah
this one guy started talking and then he
lets the guy know he goes no no no no
he's taking my energy back in the day
he'd be
we were doing this we were doing the
shoot
and this guy started talking and and and
joe goes who are you and the guy said
something and he goes
okay and the guy talks a little more and
joe goes like this he goes
holy [ __ ] what a [ __ ] artist
oh [ __ ] you're a boy he said it oh
instead right there he goes oh my god
you are such a [ __ ] artist yeah he's
not sure it was so awkward yeah and the
guy turned out to be able to [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
i was reading this article i think it
was on new york post one of those might
have been i forget what it was on maybe
my apple news but it's all about people
who are late all the time they're
they're saying that it's not actually
obviously it sucks if you work with a
person but they're saying that it's a uh
you can chalk it up to they always see
the best in people and they're always
optimistic like oh i have 15 minutes i'm
making 15 minutes when they can't that's
why in their head they're like i can i
can i can do this remember yeah yeah
yeah
i remember so that's a that's a that's a
is that right yeah that goes hand in
hand yeah they're saying people who are
late like obviously there's some
complete [ __ ] or just disrespect
people's time yeah but i would always
say like dove says you're so optimistic
with time yeah they're saying they have
an optimistic look on uh life in general
people are like they're nice people but
they're lazy
they're optimistic they're like i get 20
minutes i can do i can run the store i
can do this and most regular people like
94 you get out of your phone that's what
i always do i don't do that anymore yeah
yeah they say it's an optimistic trait
that's so easy isn't that weird it makes
sense with you that's so [ __ ] weird
it's kind of like a
like a false reality type thing dude
they just think
i go back and i'm a little bit like that
but
wow
dude can i be honest with you i like i
go back in my life and i think about
what i would do differently if i was 20
again and you're like uncle i would just
be way more of a dick if you had a time
machine i'd just be way more of a dick
i'd just be way more suspicious of
people i just wouldn't be i don't know
if you don't need to be this other but
what would happen you wouldn't be a dick
you just won't waste your time you have
to be a dick i'd
yeah i'd be i'd be actually way more
strategic i'd be like let me see i i
think what i would do
as i'd go
are you
are you successful in any facet of your
life and if not i'm probably even if
they're not there might be potential
there but you just wouldn't waste it
well yeah if someone's like if someone
was like would i know would i be able to
do that that's the question no probably
not because i like people you do like
people even if you had a time machine
though i don't know what is it about
people
i just like people i just i just see the
best in people maybe because i i
i think life is hard and if people are
not doing well it breaks my heart
i don't yeah i don't once i see people
who fell through the cracks i'm
optimistic enough to believe that
they're gonna get out they're gonna get
out from there because i always see them
yeah i've always been that way i don't
know i'm [ __ ] that was thanksgiving
it was great man was it i was with my
cousins who are all awesome and my aunt
and uncle and they cooked 33 people in
connecticut yeah that's a lot of people
i love this they're all great how was
your how was your thanksgiving cat
it was good it was my mama came over my
yeah my mom my siblings stevie and i and
we had ordered a bunch of food from
bristol farms it was really [ __ ] good
i didn't realize bristol farms made a
good like thanksgiving spread
oh [ __ ] yeah and then i went to cut a
christmas tree yesterday with stevie
yeah i saw that you went you went yeah
we went to a christmas tree farm and
then we oh and you have to cut it down
uh yeah because i had never done this
this is something he did a lot yes the
stevia and my jacket like a lumberjack
you're so good for stevie i love you
i love you guys together thanks so much
so
he's domestic so you gotta cut it he's
the best lumberjack
they only have like four or five foot
trees available to cut down i guess the
rush came in right after thanksgiving by
the time we went so we cut down a four
foot tree just to say we cut down a tree
and then we picked out one of their
pre-cut trees
but yeah stephen went dressed as paul
bunyan hell yeah and we had a great time
we brought butters and then do they
provide saws and ships yeah they had a
really rusty saw though so it takes
forever for you to cut it takes like a
legitimate steve you did it by hand yeah
i don't have that handle
they do they don't give it to everybody
though yeah one of the fun is that
you're like really get it you're working
for that goddamn tree yeah
so the real trees are beast man then the
the pine needles fall everywhere they
smell nice a bunch of bugs are in it too
so you gotta raid them down when they
get into the house she's gonna brought a
tree into my ex my ex she would
she would be in the hospital she in
fifty allergic breathe
if you're in the wilderness and you're
starving pine nuts get yourself some
pine cones find some nuts dude that's
nuts are those like really expensive
nuts they are yeah and also birds
usually are going to beat you to it yeah
little birds yeah [ __ ] birds jim
what'd you do for thanksgiving
uh me and my girl went to my parents
house had dinner there what kind of part
dinner it's actually like a lunch it was
basically all the good stuff that
american thanksgiving has but with the
some kimchi some other you know rice
inside some cream sauce and then i went
to vegas right after that
for one night
me my girl and my friend peter we got
some stuff it's over there
we can't yeah we can't and that's for me
that's for you i don't know where you're
gonna do it at but that's like legit
stuff really yeah and your kids will
probably freaking go crazy i don't think
you do that in your area i don't think
you can't either so you got to figure
out that fire has i remember you asked
me for this before so i was like i'm
there is that like the black cat [ __ ]
telling the real deal holyfield that's a
real deal it it's like use some m90s no
man m80s these are what's in the box no
there's m90s too and there's and there's
m-100s is that true yeah they go up you
gotta be m100 is like half a stick of
dynamite can i bring one over here yeah
i don't think you can get in trouble
chin they sell it in vegas yeah we're
not going to launch these anywhere we're
just we just
yeah just for fun
this will not be a california gender
reveal
oh those are like the real deal yeah but
that box right there is a crazy one get
grab that box
where'd you get this stuff
somewhere like the disney world
that box has a multiple ones and you
light it and it joe's
i guess i'll save it it looks like it
looks like disneyland but the [ __ ] of
this [ __ ] will blow up sometimes yeah so
that's why we're not going to launch it
that box has one fuse or it's multiple
in there multiple but it's just for
looks for the studio
i knew it oh hey oh no that's gonna blow
you up
we ain't got no lighters god you're a
giant [ __ ] hey what the [ __ ] my god
you never played with fireworks as a kid
nah man i don't like that explosive [ __ ]
really
no
don't make fun of me i'm gonna hurt you
look at me i'm sensitive
huh you lied away how much did you spend
on on the whole get up it's it's around
the 100
area oh it's not bad yeah not bad but
you have to pick up stuff for your
friend yeah well like a ton of what's he
doing with it no it's my girlfriend's
sister she remember she always has all
those crazy fourth of july parties yeah
we're long days from fourth of july
black friday that's the whole reason
only do you like discounts yeah did you
do any shopping on black friday you
would do something right no
no we were traveling weren't we there
were lines in new york city out the
[ __ ] store just everywhere you went
just like
dude i told my [ __ ] girl right so
there's been those thieves in north
northern california they hit uh southern
california i [ __ ] told her i said i
would bet my this is a true story i said
i would bet my bottom dollar the
nordstroms that we go to panga is the
next one she goes no i went i went it's
too easy access right to the highway why
wouldn't they do that it's right there
she goes no no no she takes she doesn't
listen to me i'm in seattle takes the
kids to the [ __ ] nordstroms
three hours later those [ __ ]
criminals hit it up i mean granted she
was gone you don't get in trouble when
you have no you do they have to tell the
attorney no they get district i'm
turning now they're just like now now in
san francisco he goes now they're going
to be arrests but finally well no they
they [ __ ] up because they robbed a
home depot and one of them had a gun and
the home depot security a little
different nordstrom shot him and killed
him i didn't know that because they were
robbing they were smart they're doing it
without guns to start right because then
they got a bunch of hammers and such
yeah whatever but when you bring guns
you're talking about different so so the
guy takes out a gun
they brought guns to the home depot and
got shot and killed where was this um i
forget in
l.a uh bring that up gin
looters and home depot get shot
but when you bring guns you're talking
about different animals no matter what
state you're in you're getting guys you
need to get shot
home depot
i don't think anybody got shot no
someone got shot and died
type in uh looters get shot
yeah i didn't my my kids went to the uh
l.a auto uh
uh
show i didn't want to go into that
well you said
lulu's getting shot bubba no it's it's
they're ransacking for sure no one got
shot i'm telling you
um
yeah it's it's crazy man oh there's
california security right shut dead oh
that's right that's where it is so he
got shot but that actually helps the
cause because once they they know they
have guns they talk about different
level of security and stuff like that
horrible
yeah
a group of eight robbers still hammers
crowbars other tools so i'm about four
hundred dollars all right i guess that's
worth it for 400 kuna nordsons
terrible
there goes group of five suspects stole
25 000 expensive purses from north store
westfield to panga that's my store
dude do you see that let's see new some
tells california mayors to step up after
mob there you go dumbass um
there you go way to go dumbass um did
you see homeboy getting uh robbed and
off melrose yeah sitting down with this
girl just dude comes up with a gun not
to be he's just watching that was
sherman oates oh yeah he took you took
home his watch that you talked about
that one the gun oh it's a guy just some
guy
i don't know
also in uh on melrose when they they got
out of the car and the dude they tried
to rob him he just went bang and just
shot at him
you saw that that was crazy man he saw
him coming he just goes oh really all
right yeah he's talking to people we
played that pulls up and he goes all
right you know yeah
who can it be getting dangerous out
there man
well
i feel better with a gun but diff on the
police where'd it go everybody the
minute you do that isn't it amazing how
big the criminals go quickly [ __ ]
show up [ __ ] just like the minute
you have a less police presence but why
would you give you an idea what happens
in english but why work yeah why
wouldn't you if you're like oh there's
not as many cops and then before i think
about if you're a criminal you're like
oh yeah yeah [ __ ] that they're all
waiting they're all like look at that
they just go but my favorite part is
those people that make those choices the
politicians their houses are surrounded
by security oh you think they they don't
deal with it because they don't they
don't everyone else suffers if you don't
live in those areas when they don't when
the aclu comes along says you're not
allowed to have any kind of search or
seizures of locker room when these kids
are getting shot your kids don't go to
that school yeah you don't even drive
through that neighborhood you [ __ ]
you know but all these politicians want
to defend the police but then they have
armed security at their house what the
[ __ ] that prize how the [ __ ] does that
mean you mean that's he doesn't live in
the neighborhoods that are affected by
crime yeah
it's not good
well i mean it's such a political
liability you know george soros helps
fund these [ __ ] crazy left-wing uh
district attorneys who say that bail is
racist so you get a guy out who just ran
his girlfriend over shot her i guess the
puncher in the face and ran her over and
then he's out on he got out and then
hacked the person with a machete i mean
see that no yeah no same thing how the
[ __ ] does that make any [ __ ] sense it
doesn't but we've gone through this
we'll see what happens
so often in this country like in the 70s
it's like he goes soft on crime [ __ ]
gets really bad and you get hard on
crime it's pendulum either swings one
way or the other and it's like
come on man
what's
trump said anything woke turns to [ __ ]
you know he has some weird quotes but
he's right about that one
yeah anything woke touches turns to [ __ ]
he's just so polarized
can you say it a different way
i think all of us i think all of us
whether you're awoke if you're you're
from magasta and wilkeville all of us
know you have to admit that the news is
telling you
something
that is not what you're seeing in your
everyday life like yeah you sell
disaster and fear of porn and for the
rest of us we're like i i'm trying to
get to work and i don't see this right
here i don't see it this crazy it just
i i need to find the truth somewhere
yeah right now it's rogan's podcast
for the most part especially with jocko
uh what did you get
so good was it i would vote for choco
for president right now yeah yeah he's
the best sensible guy yeah the possible
man
uh look if you want to send stuff if you
got to send stuff dude it's the holidays
well you want to send gifts right you're
going to do it online i'm not going to
wrap things but i might send you a
couple dudes maybe you got a merch store
you're an online store and this is the
craziest time of the year man if you
have a business you want to save money
because shipping stuff can really add up
you've got inventory you got to manage
your orders you got to fill orders
you're strategic
shipping out of holiday orders melts
away leaving you with a happier customer
more freedom to run your freaking
business and you get a little more time
off if you sell anything online whatever
it is your own merch cups
that's where ship station makes it super
easy ship station works with all the
major carriers in international and
local including fedex usps ups they even
have access to discounted rates that are
usually reserved for a fortune 500
orders from every sales channel whether
it's ebay amazon you name it you name it
man no one in 98 of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it for
as long as they're in business it's that
freaking good 88 yeah dude make this
holiday season a little brighter with
ship station use the code fighter to get
60 day free trial just enough time to
handle holiday rush because it's coming
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top and enter code fighter ship
station make ship happen
so this happened very abruptly virgil
abloh actually passed away yesterday
because of a very rare form of cancer he
was battling with
very privately for the last two years
yeah nobody knew besides his family at
least my friend out of this school
that's terrible yeah it worked fast
virgil's such a pioneer it's such a
shame he's such a pioneer so virgil's
interesting so him and kanye met they
both had internships they were both
interns at this big fashion house so him
and uh kanye i think was two on 19
2018 maybe maybe even before that but
him and kanye were both interns at this
fashion house him and kind of kicked it
off and they got it together well he
started being the head of creative for
kanye
and then obviously started his own
branch of off-white
and he was a pioneer and you know
trailblazer because with off-white what
he did for street gear street fashion is
with street fashion so he's been kind of
like shitty gear like
not the best of quality so he's like no
there's definitely quality in street
gear street fashion so he made street
fashion like high-end like really dope
street fashion really good quality stuff
that's where off white came into play
and then he became the first
african-american ever to head
uh
well at any big fashion so he's the head
of creative for louis vuitton amazing
yeah he was clearly really talented
stupid you thought about him because i
know you you you oh these shoes are he
designed these shoes yeah i'll wear
offloads every day
so what what um
when you see off white as the guys in
fashion what was it about
that brand that got your attention
uh again his his like changed the game
didn't it with street fashion because
again street fashion was always kind of
like shitty like run down stuff they
made it high-end like cool stuff
like even like these are just normal
dunks but then like you know putting the
cord on him and his writing and stuff he
just made it cool man yeah that's super
cool
yeah it's such a shame are somebody that
talented and and what i i don't know
anything about fashion but like
when you realize how many people are
trying to break into a field like that
right you know what i watched recently
it was hustle and flow that when they're
looking for the next rapper i know it's
10 years old but you know i haven't seen
it cardi b is hilarious in it cardi b
that's taraji [ __ ] you man cardi b was
uh cardi b was hustle and flow no no no
no the tv show whether whether oh god oh
my god oh the next one
okay i know i love toronto it was that
netflix show where they had the rapper
but it got me
[ __ ] dying to do it and you know what
it reminded me of is like they come up
they do their rap
so much like stand up like like i can
watch you do a set for five minutes or
three minutes two minutes and i'm like
well i know i know your influences are i
know if you're good or not i know if
you're ready or not oh yeah and it's the
same thing with rap it's like you're
you're obviously really derivative and
then once in a while somebody come along
and just you know be a game changer yeah
yeah different way
same thing with like off-white like a
guy like that who does fashion like in
this insane business he finds just a way
to be different yeah and that's just
such a unique [ __ ] guy man it's such
a shame such a bummer and to die at 41.
like what my boy was only 41. my buddy
died in his 30s and he was just getting
started and remember the influence that
all of kanye's clique has had like don c
virgil him like monsters man monsters
monsters
the bummer too is you know virgil also
did all the creative for uh
what's the jay-z
kind tiny album the throne uh what's the
throne yep he did all the creative for
that like he's helped he was the cr head
creative director of donda he's such a
monster man but it was like their whole
pack don c in chicago everyone's from
chicago don c
kanye such a shame now the off-white
shoes are through the [ __ ] roof
oh dude
through the roof i mean they were
already through the roof oh yeah but now
it's now it's like [ __ ] more
it's so sad ben and the bummer too is in
kanye talked about this he had a lot of
jealousy of virgil because he wanted to
be the head creative director of louis
vuitton and he got it so i didn't know
kanye was was has always been in the
fashion no yeah big time that was like
that was like his thing when he first
came on the screen
pink polo yeah
yeah oh so so he but but music obviously
was the thing but he was just as much
into fashion then yeah i think so yeah
ever since he came onto the scene yeah
changed the game he's always been known
for his fashion oh yeah he's always his
whole crew virgil don see him they're
all in chicago
where he's got the brown j uh
no right down there that was like one of
his that was iconic yeah that was like
an iconic look yeah because no one ever
like really
especially
no one really dressed like that
so he really liked changing i remember
that yeah
when he was doing that he was doing that
that uh spoken word thing yeah the jam
poetry yup i like that thing
yeah such a bummer man
look at him with his with his with his
backpack on us so interesting
yeah he always wore that uh
uh one of those backpacks it was all was
it always gucci
is that um that one's gucci
coach i can't tell that i don't know the
profession
he's wearing a jacket from is that cool
is that from clothes
kenneth
is that from cole he's cool he doesn't
have fashion i don't know but coach
all
right on saturday a man was discovered
as a stowaway in the compartment where
the wheels of a plane uh go in and out
he actually snuck onto the plane from
guatemala and it landed in miami he
somehow made it do you know how you want
to give this guy [ __ ] citizenship his
freedom a hundred percent he's sad
enough if you're that ballsy
do you do you know how cold it is how
many [ __ ] we have in america who
would i mean they wouldn't
did he risk his life to become an
american dude give that guy [ __ ]
singing [ __ ] i agree
he's only 26 year old yeah he's a young
guy damn at this point he has to either
apply for asylum which then he may be
able to stay in the states if he does
not apply to asylum american airlines
actually has to fly him back to
guatemala
no that's that's an ambitious
[ __ ] i know he made it all this
way
yeah how did he get up in there what
about that's still unknown right now
there's an investigation because this
absolutely
had happened i'll adopt that
[ __ ] come on
you going too
no you're not going to do [ __ ] you're
not going to adopt that guy
it's fascinating why are you why do you
even say that you probably he's probably
watching you yeah here at thick boy
studios give him a room we don't they're
all used up
but i think they should let him in yeah
let him in but you ain't adopted them no
i mean i guess what a badass yeah
was he okay
yeah he was okay that's the miraculous
thing they actually had a medic on
standby when he landed because i guess
they found out that he was there during
the flight so people were waiting for
him when they landed
they made sure that he was okay and then
took him to the hospital he was fine
badass yeah i mean come on man dude
think how bad your situation must be to
[ __ ] just [ __ ]
definitely not going to but let him know
he might be running from gangs or
something who knows i'm giving him money
you are be funny
he's a gang member yeah
yeah
here we go
do you guys know who casey neistat is
the youtuber yes very very popular
youtuber huge he actually tweeted over
the weekend saying that he was in la and
the car that he was driving got broken
into a lot of his stuff was stolen he
then blasted la for being a [ __ ] of
a city he thanked the lapd for
recovering his stuff and finding the
person who broke into his car seth rogen
found this and said that it has nothing
to do with la and everything to do with
him leaving his [ __ ] in his car so
you're nuts it's lovely here don't leave
anything valuable it's called living a
big city
yeah and i guess after that he got some
backlash from casey neistat fans but he
got lit up just in general
[ __ ] dumbass yeah he's a bit of a
he then goes on to by the way he's funny
something that's really important to
realize and i got this from rogan's
podcast with tristan harris is that a
lot of this stuff on on twitter is uh is
troll farms yeah so so they they do this
on purpose they so a lot of the [ __ ]
you're talking to some of these dm's are
not even real people but this is real
this is actually this one
yes i mean you know it's like go [ __ ]
off
but seth rogen yeah people were like
dude how privileged are you for a guy a
kid to get his [ __ ] car broke into
you like yeah deal with big city [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here man yeah
yeah it is a [ __ ] hole and it is crime
riddled and and go [ __ ] yourself not
crazy [ __ ] it's also it's
seth rogen speaking about this in his
mansion in bel air that's where it gets
dicey yeah you think got it okay he does
also refer to like him being broke and
getting his car uh broken into 20 times
within his time in l.a he's saying it's
not that big of a deal it happens
and you've been and by the way i'm sorry
i'm going to you're also here for two
months and got ridiculously famous by
sucking off uh he's [ __ ] judd
right he's been famous bro and he's not
that good i'm sorry he's okay
what says rogan do you know i think he's
talented i don't think he's out he's
okay he's okay he's all right i like him
i think he's all right i like seth rogen
yeah i think he's i don't like
he's becoming like such a woke [ __ ] but
i think i guess i don't know much about
him because i'm like oh i didn't think
he was like he's got he's very chubby
and he plays that beta male very well
and that's fine and i'm sure he's he's
not a bad guy
i in fact in fact i happen to know maybe
i'm speaking out of turn but i happen to
know that he the money he made off of
renting his very expensive apartment in
vancouver he gave he would use that
money for charity he's not a bad guy
this is not seth roll's not a bad guy
but he's just a little out of touch yeah
a little bit out of touch oh this shows
that
yeah
that's like casey ness that he can
probably uh afford casey neistat dude is
doing very well he's fine yeah they're
both rich so we're talking about ballers
this is too rich guys
i get why he's upset about saying stuff
about la though right now why did why
did seth rogens people always try to
[ __ ] on them
no i know why because he gave an
appreciation to the lapd that's why
i mean that's where it gets political oh
he's oh he said he had appreciation yeah
yeah this is where it gets political
this is it just
you know it's more well even uh
uh what's dak shepard's girl's name
kristen bell kristen bell took a picture
with that oh yeah the sheriff ella
county sheriff's sheriffs and people
just lit her up for it what a surprise
so so can i ask
why why is it that the more woke you are
the more into masks and and against the
police you are and also why is it that
you usually don't live in a neighborhood
that is riddled with crime you wouldn't
drive through the neighborhoods you're
talking about much less no they [ __ ]
never so you know what i'm saying so
yeah i know exactly it does become
political it's like
they're so out of touch i'm seth rogen
it's like dude just [ __ ]
just do your job and shut the [ __ ] up
yeah and by the way yeah just dribble
and shut the [ __ ] up yeah and then i'm
taking pictures with cops from now on
i'm just gonna plaster it all over my
[ __ ] like she got lit up for that she
got lit up for taking a picture with
like well that particular station has
had some issues
okay where they had they had like that
group that was like going after people
but the rampart division i forget what
what division was long time ago you had
a laptop and look it up
tune's all damn that's crazy man what's
your favorite yeah yeah i was on it i
was not talking that crazy [ __ ] he's
still trying to differentiate gucci and
coach okay yeah yeah and by the way even
this backlash might be [ __ ] trolls um
i'm telling you man so wait wait wait
you're giving the trolls too much credit
b
i think it's awesome
accused of glorifying violence and
members cost taxpayers tens of millions
of dollars in legal payouts
accused of racism
this sucks so much get out of here come
[ __ ] yourself
okay you go [ __ ] be a cop yeah go be
a cop you know it works out for you yeah
[ __ ] out of here this is a bad place
this is a bad place
referring to the show she's on it's
called the good place well one of you
famous whites that know christmas please
handle this what does that say
well one of you famous whites that knows
christmas
you're you're just a dumb dumb shout out
keep scrolling down they'll bring up
their uh accusations video shows debbie
slam lancaster into the ground i keep
going
uh-huh uh
yeah okay
leno's late juneteenth day all right
i had a bunch of idiots
a bunch of woke idiots hilarious yeah
that's exhausting oh my god can you
imagine living like that
so in other news matthew mcconaughey
came out in a twitter video and said
that he will not be running for governor
of texas
yeah he was he yeah that's why he made a
video he said maybe in the future but as
of right now i'm not ready
republican no we don't know he never
declared i think he's republican though
but we never know but we never know
you're right
he was smart he never did like let me
know what side he is
he never told you if he was four
vaccines again like none of it
he's a reasonable guy that's what he
sounds like
yeah
i hear his books really really good it's
great yeah you ready really it's a
really good one i like him
he grew up crazy his whole journey
through life yeah like his parents have
sex in front of him and [ __ ] what yeah
he's from he's from from texas right
right yeah he's from japan
very small town in texas
yeah yeah like hippies
let me see what he's saying here let me
watch this it's pretty cool even more
now yeah
i've been working on the answer to the
question of how i can be most useful in
this life going forward useful to myself
useful too all right i don't care
he's a little too he's just too likable
like he's such an actor sometimes i just
uh
you just felt it right there huh
the first the first three sentences when
he's sitting there talking about it he's
two flags
i'm like watching him and he's like he's
he's just he loves being
awesome around the regular folk like at
the same time
i like him yeah that's fine you hate her
after true detective you can do no wrong
in my book yeah he's good no we're so
good
yeah okay brian i mean i want to watch
yeah you were like yeah you were all
excited you're like yeah let's play this
yeah seth rogen matthew mcconaughey i
think it's all good i like them they're
all brian you've been acting a little
different since the rock thing yeah
that hurt your feelings people friends
might go it's [ __ ] man you look just
younger than the rock on my house you
said friends right thanks guys
but keyword is friends you know
i was like
those are probably russian
russian buzzers
let's get jen
uh this right
bottle here korean sentence to death oh
holy [ __ ] you can't watch greek game at
that yeah and then some student was
sharing usb drive with his friends with
the movie on it or the series on it and
he's going to have life in prison holy
[ __ ] dude
yeah sentence
they're so sweet
that's sad
that's awesome monarchy all right brian
jesus christ just no there's not much in
there oh i was like [ __ ] god just off
watching squid games not that no
sneaking it in the guy snuck it in but
the kid the kid the student was able to
get it and then send it to him
was it basically a commentary on north
korea is that the idea are they no they
don't like it because why because it's
coming from south korea
yeah
wow i forgot what they called that kind
of country but it's they call it a
certain kind of country like you know
jesus that's a terrible country
leather coats
you can wear leather yeah yeah you can't
wear you start rocking leather coats
yeah
they're just fantastic aren't they can
you imagine like right i guess i won't
wear this
your leather coat
yeah you don't like newsen
try kim jong-un
okay
um so that's pretty crazy that is north
korea though you guys already talked
about omicron
yeah we don't want to get in i know
we're growing uh but yeah so there's a
bunch of the move
the big moo variant remember that
you remember it was the big thing they
were locked back down with the mu well i
don't remember yeah it's gone now isn't
it weird
i mean yeah
which and i have one they'll hopefully
you know they realize that this is all
also i don't know how much i could show
this but remember mr beast did the squid
game oh [ __ ] look how real look how
crazy this thing is
he did a really good job on this they
said yeah god how did i not get an
invite to this
so he'll play red light green light here
and it was a paintball and no no they
have like little little you know safe
explosive devices on their stomachs oh
if you keep stuff they have they mess up
probably something similar to laser tag
what's going on
so that's one game
[Music]
i love it
it's just insane he really did recreate
all this stuff
yeah look at that the place where they
slept
did anybody die
and this look at this oh wow that's
crazy they made this awesome holy [ __ ]
dude i am so about i did the goddamn
thing and it's already had over 100
million and they have the outfits and
everything yeah he's making his money
back oh yeah
did he do the glass one
um they did
were they walking yes oh wow and this
the marbles one looks just like it too
holy [ __ ] dude he must have hired like a
real team i know he spent a ton of money
on two million on this i believe
yeah so it was legit
nobody died though nobody died nobody
died oh they do do it look at it
just the attention to detail is insane
it's nuts yeah
i guarantee this is going to be a game
that you they're probably going to have
a squid games [ __ ] like that the way
jeff has the tempest thing that'd be a
[ __ ] great way to make money just
have squid games as for parties
for your kids and stuff play all those
games i'd [ __ ] make a lot of money i
think that's [ __ ] amazing for adults
adults yeah adults don't my kid would
like her i know it would do it yeah
don't maybe i'd do it
i'd do that i'd get could you do that
yeah
yeah no you wouldn't yeah i don't think
it's like a booming business or nothing
like that
i don't like it hey seth rogen hater 100
million views bro
yeah that's great you recreated it once
you can watch the seth rogen movie what
the [ __ ]
yeah that's the funny ones man yeah it's
a really good bang super bad funny
people oh adam
oh it's great that was a good one i mean
he's adam sandler's open knocked up lion
king pineapple voice
yeah i mean i won't want them in my
foxhole if we're in a fight but
to make me laugh like entertainment
cracking up yeah i mean you got to give
it up oh yeah so i guess the
where was this at this is
yorkshire yeah
there's uh i guess there was a blizzard
that happened they were stuck in this
pub
and uh with an oasis cover band what's a
punter
i don't know what a you'd love it huh oh
i would love it in a heartbeat look at
that look at it sleep there they're
stuck in the blizzard they slept there
yeah all this stuff yeah and they said
with the covet variant
i'm sure they don't want to leave but
the thing is
[Music]
they start doing dude sounds like a
nightmare
no it doesn't
it sounds worse than me
hey rhino cowboy slabs
yeah that's
blizzard all right
layer up layer yeah
and you're assuming that band just sat
there and played they're like [ __ ] this
we don't be here either
i would have gotten up and [ __ ] just
did acoustics yeah for two elliot page
wait let's do it the elliot page yeah i
thought this was interesting
yeah so you know elliot page has
transitioned or is transitioning to
elliott
and then he posted this
good for him yeah
the interesting thing was you know same
nipples when you're a girl i can't do
that but now you can do it it is so
strange with this technology
did uh he have bottom surgery i don't
know about that
well you have to enlarge the clitoris
with hormones
wow that's crazy science is not she was
so cute by the way yeah when she first
came out yeah juno oh
generally just a cute thing but okay i
wonder what happens to her career now or
his career he's probably still killing
it or he i don't think so really yeah
probably yeah what has she been in
chappelle yeah
you you watch umbrella academy
yeah umbrella academy but she played uh
he played himself in that
i don't know i think this was
pre-transition
okay hopefully who i am all right
yeah i just
yep
don't buy it and then i mean i do but
it's interesting
she's jacked
good body
yeah
what is this i'm just seeing if he has a
penis
the information probably isn't out there
yeah i mean it's really hard to make a
penis out of a clitoris actually it'll
be kind of small right have you ever
seen pictures of it yeah there'll be i
mean the buff grows that no take
testosterone now i kind of want to see a
picture so what happens
the is and it's it's [ __ ] i'm that's
what i've
seen and read because i wanted to can't
they turn your thumb into a penis no
what no you can't what that's been done
before okay let's kill a guy but he has
the wiring that's a small dick though
you know you can take what you can get
dude i guess i i don't know if that's
true bubba but um you want a bet yeah
i'm telling you some guy gave us
it's a tough one to make a penis out of
uh you don't really have a penis i don't
think i don't know what they do
okay that's yeah don't cross you didn't
go that chin
i'm telling you uh do a guy uh
turn his thumb into penis it's a
procedure they did
he used one of his fingers
well now they're growing uh tissues
now they're gonna be able to grow your
dick surrogate penis
sorry penis
man loses penis to cancer doctors
amputate his middle finger to make it a
penis
yeah you can use your the
the skin if you feel it though it's just
there i don't know dude
so something changed
so something changed down there so it
took all like all like this whole part
right here i think yeah i think just
that part but i would do my middle
finger you know the long one
i'll do the long one hey do you want to
use that middle yeah yeah i don't know
what to say and also i'd rather have a
thumb then my middle finger got a tattoo
on it so
yeah you don't take that i mean you
don't really need the pinky yeah i don't
know yeah see finger replacement for
penises you can do it
17 hours if you have if he's a
quadriplegic i guess you transfer you
transfer sensation there's a thing your
brain does but
i'm saying you can do it man
it says 12 days afterwards he was able
to uh pass water and resume a full sex
life i'm i'm just wondering if i'm
wondering if he's going to if sh if
elliot page is going to ever work again
oh i bet you probably yeah but to the
magnitude she has been i don't know i
think you can check on our imdb to see
if she's worked on anything since yeah
who
you're saying like the future
she's gonna be like in those big
movies
be tough to be juno like she's something
she was a champion she had that good
show on vice yeah she was well she was
also a serious regular on uh i don't
know what the last show was but
um yeah what's her uh i would go imbd
quit acting trying to see it
that'd be precious
well in 2022 so gotta
animated series yeah yeah
keep going down
flatliners all right that's four years
ago she did a lot of work back then i'm
saying for sure you know
you you fundamentally changed your
entire identity and you got jobs off of
being a specific kind of gal
woman
um
and yeah
yeah for some reason i assumed she she
wouldn't care well i mean did you see
the uh he
he's did you see did you see uh sorry
um
saved by the bell
that's the truth the reboot yeah no no
you watched it no but go to saved by the
bell transgender uh she started as a man
uh a boy on the show and yeah who's
actually that jose josietoda look at
josie toto right there
right there now go yeah go to that
picture of their chin which one oh
that's what you're talking right there
yeah that that wasn't with the hair and
that went from
male to female go go go back for a
second yeah is it for the show right
there or in the blue in the blue halter
top maybe but was do was did she get
cast as a man on the show and then turn
a woman on the show yeah so she started
as a man and on the show uh i guess
that's but she's on saved by the belt so
i don't know yeah i don't care about
that yeah he looks like a female total
female was this part of the story for
the show
i don't think so oh god it cares i don't
think so yeah well there's that
transgender on uh euphoria it's great
yeah hunter schaefer she's amazing yes
really good really good
interesting
yeah she oh she's transgender yeah she's
great she's so good in the show
season season two is going to come out
soon
yeah she's creating that show
she started off as a model and then
euphoria is the first thing that she
booked i think one of her first
auditions too
jeez yeah she's great very talented
what else you got jen
let's take a look here this is a really
old one i just popped up as a i forgot
what it was but
i just found this interesting these two
fish
oh that's old it's super old right have
you guys seen this
no so they pick up rocks maybe they're
playing
i don't know because they're not in his
head oh he got him right in the face
let me get you does anybody die no no no
one dies i think tony baker did it i've
never seen
oh yeah
it's just weird i think they're just
bored as [ __ ] because they're in the
tank i always think that people were
people who did bad things in the past
life were reborn these animals and now
they're just stuck doing this this is a
form of hell that we're watching what is
[ __ ]
what is this now uh i saw this on
puberty it says we don't deserve dogs
this woman's walking with a bag
someone's gonna try to rob her
that's super cool she should took that
down that's [ __ ] crazy awesome dogs
are awesome man she's all thanks dog you
just kept going you know
i'd adopt that dog right now yeah that's
[ __ ] amazing that i believe but that
26 year old yeah guatemala or whatever i
don't think you would adopt i'd adopt
that dog and that guy from guatemala
adopt the guy
uh this is just the last one jerry
seinfeld's comedians and cars i think
he's on the last one or he's not gonna
do any more
oh but he hasn't done a new season right
no so the one that was the one that you
watched last night was the part
no no that's i think i'm going to put
the volume on the shelf
put that volume on the shelf
it was a lot of fun and got to meet a
lot of those people who had not met
we're friends now it's amazing two hours
with somebody friends forever it was oh
damn please he's saying the editing
process was insane that's one of the
reasons why i can't keep it today in
that show it's only like somewhere like
18 minutes long something new
yeah you make that much money it's like
yeah if you're him it's like i guess i
want to shoot this [ __ ] yeah
great show though i never watch uh those
are all my boys right there arnette and
who and bateman and what are you talking
about
uh they have a podcast oh smart list
yeah i sold that thing huh they sold it
did they oh yeah do you see like it
popped up my instagram feed you know you
know there's whatever you call it uh
advertising whatever there's a sponsor
the audio was just horrific it almost
sound like they're recording from their
phones
it's on spotify now they have paid i
think 80 mil or something like that wow
i mean the cast they're great it's just
the audio they probably moved to the
studio but yeah in the beginning it was
weird oh hell yeah yeah it's just i
i'm just
hold on he says i don't know maybe it's
me but for some reason i can't ever
truly lose myself and he says nice
vacation without thinking about everyone
else we all must rise and he just
videotapes himself yeah
[ __ ] yeah rise up dog
keeps looking at the camera he doesn't
say anything
this is it this and he's all flexing his
arm right yeah
well he's just in hawaii on a
four-wheeler
yeah like one of those can-ams
hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah
this is the whole video yeah and he
licks his lips
just blows you around
i think he's isn't he jewish and black
yeah he's mixed down now i'd watch this
for 12 hours
it's just more of that
he's just a trip he's
yeah
he's such a true [ __ ]
surprise wellness rise thanks for the
hit that's everything about everybody
else yeah
wow he's trying to connect you get out
of touch i get out of touch a little bit
that long his fans love it though yeah
so we're rising family
family dude
oh my god family yep dude he's crushing
it man all right well let him do it
is that it that's it fast and furious
10.
he's killing him i don't need you to see
the rock if you like fast and furious if
those the franchise you'll really like
me you'll really like me at the laughing
spree in boca this old and furious old
and furious uh and then i'm in uh well
okay but i'm i'm also in oklahoma city
oh man let's just do this i'm gonna do
this from now on quit doing i know i
need those graphics anymore uh kansas
city improv december 17 18 19. december
15th i'm gonna be at chop house six i'm
doing that [ __ ] sticking with it yeah
good for you man stick with it yeah i
won't be there i'll do a couple of shows
um oklahoma city salt lake city utah
wise guys january 6 7 8.
uh come see me all right go see him
uh chappelle you're in san jose
wednesday night
improv san jose improv man my last
headlining show of the year so uh make
sure you come wednesday night 8 pm go
out and see them san jose that's one
night only for chappelle lacy man san
jose let's go let's go and then i'm
taking most december off but december
30th through january 1st bringing the
new year with your thick friends dania
florida fort lauderdale improv basically
we are doing the goddamn thing florida
so come on out
f-a-t-k-z.com come get your tickets fort
lauderdale let's do this how do you say
dania dania florida dania yeah i think
it's the old fort lauderdale
dania dania dania dania dania
and then we have a fight companion next
one cowbest fight companion is december
11th we also have one december 18th so
stay tuned for that oh also i had a new
merch drop oh
calm edit new merch drop down you didn't
get a t-list i'm wearing david shakes
lucas got merch uh go down gym shop now
i got new stuff that i gotta love let me
get that yellow shirt yellow long sleeve
i gotta get some all that stuff those
are dope yes so new merch policy dot com
for that oh check out conspiracy social
club on rockfin rockfin.com conspiracy
social club
love you